[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique sur lcp et public
sénat très heureuse de vous retrouver
nous sommes ensemble pour une heure
d'émission l'actualité est chargée
puisque nous sommes à moins de 15 jours
du premier tour des élections
législatives la campagne officielle
s'ouvre ce lundi pour le premier tour
qui se tiendra le 12 juin prochain mais
l'actualité ce sont aussi ces scènes de
chaos au stade de france samedi soir qui
font réagir les oppositions va essayer
d'y voir plus clair sur les
dysfonctionnements sur les
responsabilités aussi on va parler de
l'ukraine alors qu'un journaliste a été
tué aujourd'hui on l'a appris tout à
l'heure alors qu également catherine
colonna effectué sa première visite en
tant que ministre des affaires
étrangères à kiel première visite aussi
d'un représentant français sur place
dans un quart d'heure tam produits et
clément méric nous rejoindront pour
interroger notre invité sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur les retraites le gel des
loyers ou encore la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et puis enfin notre
partenaire le figaro sera bien
représentée avec vincent roux qui sera
en duplex dans quelques instants et bien
sûr if thréard à la fin de cette
émission pour parler de tous ces thèmes
nous recevons patrick mignola bonsoir
bonsoir
vous êtes président du groupe modem ici
à l'assemblée nationale merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je le disais en
titre le journaliste français frédéric
leclerc imhoff a été tué aujourd'hui en
ukraine par un éclat d'obus alors qu'il
accompagnait des civils à bord d'un bus
humanitaire emmanuel macron a redit le
soutien inconditionnel de la france aux
journalistes qui font le difficile
métier d'informer sur des théâtres de
guerre catherine colonna la ministre des
affaires étrangères a condamné un double
crime qui visait un convoi humanitaire
et un journaliste c'est un crime de
guerre patrick mignola sans aucun doute
et moi je pense d'abord à sa famille ses
proches
je pense à sa rédaction bfm et puis à
tous les journalistes parce qu'on dit
jamais assez que pour nous informer
parce que nous ne connaîtrions pas les
crimes de guerre nous connaîtrions pas
ce qu'est la situation sur le terrain on
pourrait pas se faire notre propre
opinion cerci avait pas des journalistes
comme lui comme tous les autres
aujourd'hui qui symbolise on serait dans
la situation du peuple russe qui ne sait
pas ce qui se passe sur son preuve dans
son propre pays est-ce qu'on peut encore
envoyer des journalistes en ukraine
je crois qu'on doit
je crois qu'on doit c'est très difficile
c'est leur choix personnel
mais il est impératif que on ne puisse
pas mentir aux populations et les seuls
qui nous préserve du mensonge sont les
journalistes donc faut simplement lui
rendre hommage aujourd'hui on fera une
enquête il faut évidemment une enquête
internationale il faut savoir pourquoi
alors qu'ils étaient dans un bus de
civils il faut rappeler ça
il a pris un éclat d'obus ça veut dire
que ce but ce
qu'avait dit civil qui fuyait pour des
raisons humanitaires un endroit où il
pouvait plus rester sur le territoire
ukrainien ça veut dire que ce bus a été
bombardé et donc c'est un élément de
plus deux des erreurs qui sont commises
par l'armée russe en ukraine catherine
colonna la nouvelle mine et des affaires
étrangères était à kiev aujourd'hui où
elle a rencontré vladimir celle inscrit
il y va pour apporter le soutien
évidemment du peuple français au peuple
ukrainien pour le président français
emmanuel macron ne se rend pas à qui
avait il a été invité plusieurs fois
déjà
alors je vais vous dire ce que j'en
pense personnellement parce que
évidemment ça fait pas partie de mes
prérogatives ni de mes compétences comme
simplement parlementaire moi je crois
que le président de la république devra
un jour aller à kiev pour finaliser une
négociation et je comprends bien qu'il
ya une sorte de frustration des
populations occidentales et des médias
quand du mal à imaginer qu'on est sans
doute face à une guerre longue or c'est
ce qu'il va se passer et donc il faut
qu'on poursuive la ligne qui a été fixé
par le président de la république qui à
la fois une ligne de dialogue et de
sanctions avec la russie il faut dire
qu'on continue à rechercher dans les
jours qui viennent une solution à
l'échelle européenne pour que l'on
continue pas acheter du pétrole russe et
donc indirectement à financer la guerre
parce que là
aujourd'hui donc l'embargo sur le
pétrole russe et doux avec la hongrie
comment on peut trouver néanmoins une
position européenne
de l'action de l'union européenne en
tout cas tout ça posera des questions
institutionnelles dans les années qui
viennent notamment sur la règle de
majorité la règle d'unanimité à
l'échelle de l'union européenne sa
menace la cohésion finalement l'union
européenne
le la règle de l'unanimité
menace la capacité d'action politique de
l'union et si comme je le pense nous
vivons dans un monde de plus en plus
incertain est de plus en plus dangereux
nous avons besoin demain d'avoir une
souveraineté stratégique militaire
économique à l'échelle de l'union
européenne la règle d'une ligne de
l'unanimité ne pourra pas s'appliquer
attention quand on remet en cause la
règle de l'unanimité ça signifie que ces
y compris la parole de la france qui
parfois pour être contredite par une
règle majoritaire mais je crois qu'il
faut accepter ça parce que désormais on
a besoin de protéger à nouveau le
territoire européen et pour terminer ce
que ce que nous visions sur le crâne je
crois qu'il faut qu'on continue et c'est
tout le sens de la présence de catherine
colonna sur le terrain faut qu'on
continue aussi une ligne de soutien et
de financement à l'ukraine
parce que nous serons dans une guerre
longue et qu'il faut que l'ukraine
puisse continuer de se défendre alors la
diplomatie continue en attendant
emmanuel macron et et olaf scholz ont
demandé ce week-end à vladimir poutine
d'entamer des négociations directes et
sérieuse avec volodymyr l1 ce qui est ce
que vous pensez que vladimir poutine va
s'arrêter s'il n'a pas remporté au moins
une victoire et peut-être dans le
donbass ce que je pense ne compte pas
ce que je crois ce que j'espère c'est
que
emmanuel macron qui je crois a été un
très bon représentant de l'union
européenne depuis le début de cette
guerre va poursuivre et amplifier les
efforts il ya
probablement un argument que pour
entendre la dîmière poutine c'est si
l'europe est capable de se mettre
d'accord pour arrêter d'acheter du
pétrole russe je sais que c'est un
effort qui est plus important dans
d'autres pays qu'en france puisque nous
sommes beaucoup moins dépendants du
pétrole parce que nous avons du
nucléaire et que nous avons beaucoup
d'hydroélectricité c'est un effort très
important que nous demandons à nos
partenaires allemands qui ont renoncé au
nucléaire et donc sont très dépendants
du pétrole russe c'est un effort très
important qu'on demande aux italiens
quand une augmentation de 70 % de leur
prix de l'énergie 70% du prix de
l'énergie on va reparler de cela c'est
la seule manière de faire c'est la seule
sanction tu te permets de dire que je
crois pour que les armes cessent
il faut que les portefeuilles s'assèche
on va passer à une autre actualité avec
cette réunion ministérielle qui s'est
tenue en urgence ce matin pour cerner
les dysfonctionnements au stade de
france je vous rappelle la finale de la
ligue des champions a été perturbé
samedi soit de nombreux supporters n'ont
pu accéder au stade en raison d'un
trafic de 30 à 40 mille faux billets qui
a bloqué temporairement l'entrée du
stade de france à saint-denis par la
ministre des sports et gérald un matin
on se sont exprimés à l'issue de cette
conférence de presse il s'agit
principalement d'une mauvaise gestion
des supporters britanniques muni en
partie de faux billets qui a provoqué
ces débordements est-ce qu'on peut
uniquement reporter la faute sur les
supporters britanniques
si je peux vous faire une confidence
j'étais très en colère hier soir sur ce
sujet parce que alors qu'on a donné une
très mauvaise image de la france et de
ses capacités d'organisation
d'aucuns essayait de reporter la faute
les uns sur les autres or c'est pas des
coupables il faut trouver des solutions
ou c'est pas se dédouaner qu'il faut
essayer de comprendre les
responsabilités aussi il faut comprendre
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres sauf que chacun les connaît il ya
eu une grève de rer qui a déjà mis tout
le monde en difficulté il faudra en
tirer les conséquences pour les
événements à venir il faut que le
dialogue social vives au sein de la ratp
au sein de la sncf parce qu'on voit bien
que on aurait pu y aura des morts hier
soir c'est ça qui aurait pu arriver au
delà même de l'image de la france y
aurait pu voir des morts sur le terrain
ensuite il ya le premier filtrage n'est
pas pu fonctionner et pour cause puisque
tout le monde arrivé en même temps en
tout cas parler même cheminement ensuite
il ya eu effectivement ce problème de
billets puisque l'uefa a accepté qui est
des billets papier au lieu d'avoir des
billets seulement électroniques qui sont
moins falsifiable et enfin il ya eu de
la délinquance qui voyant le désordre
généralisé on a eu des délinquants venus
des cités marine le pen a accusé des
bandes de voyous de seine-saint-denis
et débordements eric zemmour dénoncer
les racailles aussi du département de
seine-saint-denis
non mais chacun chacun essaie de
projeter ses propres obsessions dans le
sujet moi je pense qu'il faut trouver
des solutions pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que gouvernement a bien fait
de convoquer une réunion en urgence et
mettant tout le monde autour de la table
on n'a pas vu arriver les hordes du
grand remplacement
sur le sur le terrain à la à côté du
stade de france on a vu comme d'habitude
200 à 300 jeunes délinquants venir
puisque voyant le désordre ils se sont
dit que c'était l'occasion de ici piquer
un portable ici piquer un billet mais on
connaît ça malheureusement presque tous
les dimanches en france dans les matchs
de village vous en avez deux ou trois
délinquants qui embête tout le monde et
puis dans les matchs de niveau régional
vous en avez 30 et puis dans les matchs
de niveau national ou international
commis hier vous en avez 300 dans ce cas
là la police sait répondre parce que
nous avons réglé cette question depuis
désormais plusieurs années déjà on sait
les appréhender et on sait ensuite les
amener devant les juges si le faire une
incidente de ce point de vue là c'est
mieux dans ce cas là de les condamner
notamment de l'éloignement des stades et
des enceintes sportives plutôt qu'à des
stages de citoyenneté je ferme la
parenthèse
mais nous savons gérer ça et en
l'occurrence la police ait eu du mal à
digérer parce que effectivement
auparavant l'ensemble des filtrages
n'avait pas fonctionné justement
question sur la police et ce cas pas là
un déni du gouvernement sur les
responsabilités policière jean-luc
mélenchon a mis en cause la doctrine de
l'emploi de là police alors que des
centaines de supporters ont été gazés à
la une de la presse britannique un
enfant de 9 ans a été gazé des familles
étaient là il ya eu des matraques
haussier sur des personnes qui étaient
en terrasse oui mais vous venez de
résumer en quelques phrases la vie
politique française d'aujourd'hui
madame le pen et monsieur zemmour
explique que tout ça c'est la faute des
racailles et monsieur mélenchon explique
que tout ça c'est la faute de la police
moi je dis et c'est la position du
gouvernement et je le soutiens en cela
que face à un problème on regarde d'où
sont venus les désordres comment les
règles et comment ça ne se reproduit pas
là on voit bien qu'il ya eu une
accumulation de 4 ou 5 des ordres pour
conduire à quelque chose comparé donc ce
n'est pas un problème de sous-effectif
au-dessous des anticipations
on voit que les trente à quarante mille
faux billets ou un problème dans les
services de renseignements de
6000 policiers alors qu'habituellement
ils sont 1200 autour du stade de france
donc je pense que c'était suffisamment
dimensionné mais évidemment
le premier filtrage n'a pas pu se faire
dans de bonnes conditions et que
personne ne s'attendait à ce que les
40000 anglais qui venait en plus des
supporters munis de billets allait aussi
venir aux abords du stade de france
alors vous le savez c'est l'ouverture de
la campagne officielle aujourd'hui pour
les élections législatives et le premier
tour qui se tiendra le 12 juin prochain
on a beaucoup entendu jean luc mélenchon
on dira qu'il serait premier ministre et
les émois at-il dit déjà entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
voilà la majorité fait profil bas est ce
que vous ne manquez pas un peu d'élan
pour ces élections
écoutez je crois pas en tout cas on a
effectivement pas les mêmes formes de
vociférations jean luc mélenchon pour
autant
le président de la république a fixé
une ligne d'ambition et tout le travail
de la majorité c'est de la porter sur le
terrain et pour espérer pouvoir la
porter ensuite à l'assemblée nationale
et quel est l'enjeu
il est presque aussi important qu'au
lendemain de la crise de 29 ce qu'a
proposé emmanuel macron lors de
l'élection présidentielle je crois qu'on
l'a pas suffisamment souligné c'est
l'équivalent du new deal de roosevelt ce
que nous avons fait pendant la crise en
soutenant l'économie ce que nous avons
fait au lendemain de la crise avec le
plan de soutien à l'économie ce que nous
faisons avec france 2030 la
relocalisation industrielle
les investissements en matière
écologique est ce que là nous proposons
en matière de pouvoir d'achat aussi bien
pour les retraités que pour la fonction
publique que pour les minima sociaux que
pour les salariés du privé c'est un
changement de paradigme c'est un
changement de société et donc c'est ça
qu'il nous faut porter sur le terrain
alors c'est peut-être
moins spectaculaire que le mariage forcé
ou l'alliage contre nature qui a essayé
de mettre en place jean luc mélenchon
mais on sait que tout ça de toute façon
ces désunions à durée déterminée
demain aux responsabilités il faudra
répondre aux inquiétudes des français on
l'a évoqué avec l'ukraine mais dans une
société qui va devenir celle du plein
emploi ça va être notre combat de tous
les jours et celle de l'inflation il
faut qu'on apporte des réponses pour
l'avenir
jean luc mélenchon bouge un peu plus moi
j'ai le sentiment qui il apporte des
réponses à des questions du passé vous
pensez que ce sera un vote amplification
comme en 2017 pour la majorité moi je
pense sur un vote très différent de 2017
en 2017 c'était un peu comme en 2012 en
faveur de françois hollande ou en 2007
en faveur de nicolas sarkozy c'était
effectivement un vote de répliques au
sens technique du terme là je crois pas
que ce sera ce soit le cas
on a un président de la république qui a
été réélu
mais il n'a pas été réélu seulement pour
lui-même il a été répondu réélu parce
que le la société et le monde était en
train de changer
il l'a redit d'ailleurs très bien lors
de sa cérémonie d'investiture c'est pas
lui qui a changé c'est pas nous qui
avons changé c'est le monde qui a changé
et que la france a changé également
quand on se retrouve parce qu'on a
vaincu le chômage de masse des vues plus
personne ne parle du chômage dans cette
élection on a vécu le chômage de masse
on va aller vers la société du plein
emploi on se retrouve
dans une forme de démondialisation et
mais c'est intéressant parce que oui sur
la reprise économique et une forte
reprise économique au lendemain qui
aujourd'hui dans une forme de
démondialisation parce qu'à la fois la
crise sanitaire et la crise ukrainiennes
ont ralenti les échanges internationaux
et donc on va se trouver dans cette
société où on a à la fois une faible
croissance et beaucoup d'inflation et
donc la question du partage de la valeur
pour augmenter les salaires pour
s'adapter à l'inflation
c'est un changement de doctrine
économique majeur et on va en parler
dans un tout petit instant parce qu'on
va reparler du pouvoir d'achat avec tam
tran huy on écoute on synthétique on est
dans un débat de société ça va être ça
le long jeu des élections législatives
alors patrick mignola je propose qu'on
prenne la direction du figaro pour
retrouver notre partenaire et vincent
roux qui est en duplex bonsoir vincent
vous êtes en jpeg delà de la rédaction
du figaro live et vous aviez une
question sur le pass vaccinale pour
notre invité oui puisqu'on parle des
débats des questions de société patrick
mignola il ya une question de société
qui a été soulevée finalement il ya
quelques semaines il ya quelques mois
par un nouveau collègue à l'assemblée à
l'assemblée de la majorité
présidentielle même s'il est l omc
julien moreau vix qui avait déclaré je
ne vois pas comment on peut maintenir le
pass vaccinale au delà du 31 juillet
2022 31 juillet 2022 parce que c'est la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui a
été votée au mois de janvier dernier
quelle est votre position quelle sera la
position du modem à ce moment là est-ce
qu'il faut prolonger l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est ce qu'il faut prolonger le
pass vaccinale selon vous savez qu'on a
eu à s'exprimer à plusieurs reprises sur
les questions de délais et notamment le
groupe que je préside le groupe modem a
été très sourcilleux sur la question de
la fixation de ces dates moi je pense
que le 31 juillet est une bonne date
d'ici là
il n'y a que trois choses qui doivent
présider à notre réflexion la science la
science la science
servir la science qu'elle sera
le niveau pandémique dans la société
est ce que demain on peut pas imaginer
que on aura un nouveau variant est donc
il sera absolument nécessaire en
particulier pour les plus fragiles dans
la société on a déjà avancés continuent
à l'automne il faudrait vacciner cette
vaccination exactement moi je pense
qu'il faut faire très attention à ça
c'est si si demain grâce à la
vaccination il ya moins de complications
sanitaires tant mieux
prolonger bien sanitaires mais comme je
vous le dis et bien par préférence par
choix politique par engagement du groupe
modem et nous voulons éviter tous les
régimes d'exception qui sont privatives
de libertés publiques mais moi je ne
peux pas dire aujourd'hui nul mais moi
je ne peux pas dire aujourd'hui ce que
sera la situation sanitaire au 31
juillet parce que sinon je vous mange
fait de la démagogie et je dis à tous
ceux qu'elle soit le pass vaccinale
qu'on va l'enlever et c'est pas ma
responsabilité à 100 quel sera le
curseur quel sera le curseur alors à
quel niveau le curseur c'est comme on
l'a fait depuis le début de la pandémie
vous savez à quel point ça a été
difficile parfois de prendre des
décisions de cet ordre là qu'était
privatives de libertés publiques c'est
le niveau pandémique c'est l'avis de la
haute autorité de santé c'est avec comme
horizon
principal ultime obligatoire la
protection des plus fragiles dans le
pays et à partir de là si au 31 juillet
on a la possibilité de lever l'état
d'urgence sanitaire évidemment le lèvera
la décision vous l'apprenait camp
puisque c'est le 31 de toute façon on
aura à prendre une décision dans les
trois semaines qui précèdent j'invite
donc d'ailleurs à bien bien observer ce
que pourrait être une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale qui a été plus
qu'ambiguë
s'il s'agissait de nu baisse est de la
france insoumise de jean luc mélenchon
sur les questions du pass vaccinale
entendu merci mon sens vous avez votre
réponse merci à vous très mme tran huy
pour public sénat clément méric dès le
cp nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau etc
vous tam qui ai commencé à interroger
patrick mignola sur les mesures de
pouvoir d'achat rue louisbourg soit
patrick mignola effectivement vous avez
commencé à parler du pouvoir d'achat
c'est la première priorité des français
pendant la campagne présidentielle
pendant cette campagne des législatives
on connaît beaucoup des mesures du
paquet du point d'achat qui va être
présenté alors pourquoi attendre après
les législatives pour les présentait
justement ces mesures en conseil des
ministres parce qu'il faut savoir
expliquer aux français que ces mesures
coûteront de l'argent vous avez raison
au fond ça pourrait être réglementaire
s'est pas seulement du législatif mais
il ya aussi du budgétaire et il faudra
que au même moment que nous présentons
les mesures de pouvoir d'achat nous
présentions une rectification du budget
de la défense pour choeur on ne demande
pas aux français mais si on avait quand
même ces mesures de façon beaucoup plus
clair aujourd'hui ne serait ce pas
beaucoup plus simple pour vous de faire
campagne sur toutes ces mesures qui sont
moi je pense qu populaire pour les
français sont extrêmement claires
d'abord on voulait pas avoir le débat et
les oppositions maintenant on prend pas
de mesures on prend pas de mesure
seulement pour être populaire on prend
des mesures parce que c'est nécessaire
et à président de la république lui même
été très clair pendant la campagne
présidentielle on indexe les pensions de
retraite sur l'inflation on débloque le
point d'indicé de la fonction publique
pour s'adapter aussi à l'inflation
conséquemment on le fait aussi pour les
minima sociaux parce que sont les
personnes les plus fragiles dans la
société qui souffre de l'inflation
aujourd'hui et on triple la prime
pouvoir d'achat pour que les salariés du
privé puissent partout où c'est possible
dans les entreprises privées accompagné
aussi le l'échelle de l'inflation lors
vous dit billy gagner mais immédiatement
rebouc le ça et c'est là que c'est très
important par de grandes lois à passer
pendant l'été sur la participation
l'intéressement l'actionnariat salarié
ça sera dans leur projet parce qu'il
n'est pas possible non ce sera une
deuxième loi parce que ça il faut qu'on
le fasse dans le cadre d'une deuxième
hall la première aide d'urgence triplé
la prime macron et ensuite il faut que
dans toutes les entreprises on facilite
un meilleur partage de la valeur ou ça
vienne depuis 20 ans on a plus rémunérer
le capital que le travail dans notre
pays
dans ses passions ça se décide par une
loi et que ce dès le mois de juillet
exactement pour faciliter pour faciliter
un meilleur partage de la valeur c'est
très important je rappelais tout à
l'heure qu'on allait dans une société de
l'inflation mais d'une croissance plus
faible que celle qu'on attendait et donc
la question d'un meilleur partage de la
valeur ou quand une entreprise d'un
dividende un actionnaire elle donne
aussi un dividende un salarié c'est
fondamental aussi en terme de projet de
société justement sur l'inflation il ya
donc une inflation notamment des
distributeurs alimentaires ça va
augmenter de vie pour cent vous dit que
tout est très clair sur ce texte le
montant de chaque alimentation sans le
connaît non justement ils sont en train
de le regarder et pourquoi donc on le
connaît pas donc ça ne m'est pas si tout
n'est pas que le débat
pouvait juger un dossier pour ça donc ça
sera indexée sur l'inflation mais il ya
des réponses extrêmement simple quand
vous dites que vous a dit que c'est une
politique sur l'inflation c'est un
changement énorme nos parents nos grands
parents avaient vécu dans une société de
l'inflation mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'avoir
une conférence permanente sur les prix
et sur les salaires c'est moi j'avais
appelé à une conférence nationale sur
les salaires ouverte au dialogue social
avec l'ensemble des syndicats
représentatifs d'ampli c'est extrêmement
important et il faut qu'on ait le même
type d'observation pour s'adapter à
l'inflation et aujourd'hui on nous dit
part ça peut être peut-être être 10% sur
l'alimentation moi j'ai entendu certains
de nos concurrents qui disent on va
bloquer les prix oui dans les médias ce
que demande la nied ps jean luc
mélenchon la nuit ps propose de bloquer
les
doigts et donc qu'est ce qui va se
passer si on bloque les prix on va créer
de la pénurie on créera encore plus
d'inflation et qu'est ce qui va se
passer chez la grande distribution moi
je vous le dit d' avance ils feront
mourir les petits exploitants agricoles
parce que pour bloquer les primes et
maintenir ses marges eh ben c'est aux
producteurs qu'on le fera payer dire
c'est michel edouard leclerc en a rêvé
jean luc mélenchon veut le faire il ya
des noms généraliser le shaq
alimentation
jeudi le généraliser parce que pour
l'instant effectivement ça sera prévu
pour les plus précaires les plus
modestes si on arrive à une inflation de
8 10% sur l'alimentation ça va comme il
faut pétrole il faut pas penser qu'ils
ont besoin démagogue sur ces sujets là
il faut que ce soit pour les plus
précaires et qu'on ouvre très largement
pour les classes moyennes parce que 1,1
des
uns des malheurs notre société j'allais
lire un des cancers de notre société
c'est la façon dont elle traite ses
classes moyennes les gens qui
travaillent et qui s'en sortent pas les
gens qui travaillent qui gagne toujours
trop pour avoir des aides mais jamais
assez pour vivre comme il faut donc à
combien ont besoin de chaque habitation
c'est ce que je viens de vous décrire je
sais si je voyais bien que mon
énumération
valeur de vous ennuyer un peu mais je
n'ai pas dit ce que je voulais dire sur
les salaires de la fonction publique les
salariés du privé les pensions de
retraites si on s'adapte à l'inflation
là on a tout cette france qui
travaillent ou qui a travaillé qui va
pouvoir avoir un pouvoir d'achat
permettant de s'adapter à l'inflation en
revanche la question de ceux qui sont
tout en bas de l'échelle c'est
complètement différent parce que une
augmentation de 12% du prix des pâtes de
12% du prix des beliebers de 8% de des
légumes frais ou des fruits c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose quand vous
touchez 880 euros par mois et quand vous
touchez 2500 euros par mois à 2500 euros
par mois il faut que l'on puisse
augmenter les salaires et c'est ça la
vision que nous portons dans la société
dire que globalement au fur et à mesure
que l'inflation augmente il faut qu'on
puisse augmenter les salaires du public
et du privé pour s'adapter à l'inflation
mais en revanche on sait que l'inflation
fait d'abord souffrir les plus fragiles
et c'est à ça que sert le chèque
alimentation après un un mot simplement
il faut que le chèque alimentation
permet aussi de faire muter notre
appareil agroalimentaire et donc ceci
local du du local bio
du respectueux de l'environnement de la
biodiversité du bien-être animal qui
évite le les polluants les intrants le
chèque alimentation
sociale de leur pouvoir d'achat
sur le gaz ou l'électricité alors il va
être prolongé jusqu'à la fin de l'année
bruno le maire a réaffirmé aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y aura pas de rattrapage sur la
facture d'électricité des français
sauf qu'il ya quand même un manque à
gagner pour les fournisseurs
d'électricité qui va falloir compenser
alors qui va payer et c'est pour ça que
je dis que parce qu'on essaie de dire la
vérité aux français et qu'on va pas
raser gratis il faut qu'au moment où on
prolonge le bouclier tarifaire au moment
où on fait le chèque alimentation y ait
un projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour qu'on inscrive dans ce
projet de loi de finances que c'est bien
l'état l'argent public qui comprend à
l'état
c'est un peu un tour de passe passe ça
veut dire bah non si c'est pas sur la
facture des clients
les impôts payés par les contribuables
et donc vous observez que comme on
n'augmente pas les impôts ça voudra dire
faire des efforts par ailleurs ailleurs
évidemment évidemment c'est le il n'y a
pas de magie ya jamais de miracle en
matière budgétaire ça veut dire que
forcément on devrait être si on veut
tenir un bon niveau d' équilibre des
finances publiques et que l'on fait pas
payer la facture aux français ni par
l'augmentation de l'énergie ni par
l'augmentation des impôts il faudra que
par ailleurs en effet on fasse des
efforts en face notamment et vous avez
des vous avez des deux listes avec
noémie est là aujourd'hui et on est au
domaine on est obligé de faire du
décalage budgétaire sur un certain
nombre d'investissements on voit bien
comment ça va se présenter il ya l'enjeu
en réalité
pour les deux à trois exercices
budgétaires qui viennent ça va être
l'enjeu du plein emploi parce que si on
est capable de réussir le plein emploi
et que ainsi on ramène plus de
ressources fiscales et plus de
ressources sociales dans le budget de
l'état on pourra s'en sortir parce qu'il
est évidemment pas question de ne pas
tenir notre parole sur le ségur ne pas
permettre d'embaucher plus de monde dans
le secteur médico-social et dans les
ehpad et dans les maisons de retraite et
que
l'assurance-chômage aussi oui bien sûr
mais ça irait ensemble c'est sur
l'assurance chômage aujourd'hui je pense
que la première ministre a raison
de temporiser un peu pour discuter avec
les syndicats de salariés
parce qu'on rentre dans une société du
plein emploi on va avoir besoin à
nouveau voir les règles de l'assurance
chômage le principe est simple
les règles d'assurance chômage quand la
société est en difficulté économique
elles doivent être assouplies et en
revanche quand on a une société
économique qui va mieux pas
effectivement faut qu'on soit plus
exigeants en matière d'assurance chômage
dans une vision très simple sur
l'assurance chômage c'est ceux qui sont
le plus éloignés de l'emploi on doit les
indemniser plus et plus longtemps parce
qu'il leur faut plus de temps pour
revenir sur le marché de l'emploi en
revanche ceux qui sont près de l'emploi
qui pourrait retravailler il ya aucune
raison qui reste deux mois ou trois mois
de plus au chômage alors qu'il a des
besoins dans le btp dans l'hôtellerie
dans le restaurant
social pour s'occuper réduira le montant
la location on réduira le temps
seulement moi je crois qu'il ya vraiment
une question de temps
aujourd'hui le des personnes qui sont
très éloignées de l'emploi parfois j'ai
pas peur de le dire même si c'est pas
populaire parfois parce qu'ils sont
fragiles il ya besoin de les indemniser
pendant plus de 18 mois parce qu'il faut
vraiment les faire remonter dans le
train de de l'insertion dans la société
c'est extrêmement important on leur doit
plus d'accompagnement pour qu'ils aient
une deuxième chance ou une troisième
chance dans la vie en revanche celui qui
peut travailler il n'y a aucune raison
qu'il attende un peu plus et je ne fais
pas de caricature je fais pas de
démagogie là-dessus dire mais assez
logiquement si vous voulez rester quatre
points au chômage n'y a pas de raison
que vous restiez pas quatre mois revenir
sur le bouclier tarifaires et sur ses
conséquences ça fragilise un peu plus de
df qui était déjà dans une situation
financière très délicate avec une
production d'électricité en forte baisse
cette année avec des surcoûts des
dépassements de coûts sur les oeufs prs
que vous êtes favorable à une
renationalisation totale d'edf peut-être
pour l'aider à mener à bien les
chantiers des futures centrales
nucléaires françaises vous pouvez
éventuellement recapitaliser edf mais
pas nécessairement renationaliser on est
effectivement devenu situation difficile
vous le dites non vous était pas
favorable
vous avez un élément qui est très
important sur edf c'est sa capacité
d'investissement sur les nouveaux outils
ni clair sur lequel président de la
république s'est engagé et le nous vous
utile et draw électrique pour moi qui
fus un élu des montagnes
eh bien le l'enjeu que les barrages
restent
sous entreprises publiques voilà que
jamais on puisse les ouvrir à la
concurrence et que demain ce soient des
investisseurs étrangers qui en
détiennent tout ou partie savon du quai
voltaire les barrages ou aussi pour
l'ensemble du renouvelable l'éolien le
solaire il ya une filiale d'edf qui doit
quand même voté à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la loi sur la prolongation du
service public de la compagnie nationale
du rhône c'est moi qui les porter devant
que voilà j'espère bien portait
exactement le même type de loi ça les
barrages je crois qu'il faut définir
dans tous les métiers d'edf ce qui
relève de
l'indépendance stratégique du pays et ça
ça doit rester intégralement publics et
s'il le faut nationaliser et puis il ya
d'autres métiers qui sont des métiers
qui sont ouverts à la concurrence auquel
edf a des vraies qualités en cinquième
il faut qu'il continue sur l'exportation
d'électricité sur la distribution
d'électricité il ya des vraies qualités
d'edf il ya aussi des capacités sur la
construction de deux nouvelles centrales
parce que demain si vous voulez faire de
l'hydrogène vert il va bien falloir se
s'appuyer sur des compétences très
importantes à l'intérieur d'edf et
parfois ils pourront avoir intérêt
intérêt à venir sur le marché
concurrentiel parce qu'ils remporteront
des marchands que ce qu'on comprend en
tout cas un recapitalisation ou des
renationalisations
pas forcément
c'est une évidence pour moi le nucléaire
l'hydroélectricité c'est évidemment
publique et nationale sur d'autres
métiers ça peut être l'intérêt d'edf de
police avaient déjà eu des points dans
la cfdt réclame +2 3% et le modem vous
voulez combien
sur le dégel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
ont dit qu'on s'adapte à l'inflation on
n'est pas dans une compet vous voyez la
cfdt
s'accroît du mois de quoi de 2,2 mais
deux jours c'est 5,4
c'est moi je pense que il faut que le
l'ensemble de la représentation
syndicale travail avec la première
ministre pour déterminer ce que doit
être le dégel de points du point
d'indicé et nous ensuite pour le coup on
en tirera les conséquences à l'assemblée
nationale pour mettre les budgets qui
vont en face
mais oui c'est à plusieurs reprises en
plus de questions mais c'est quoi le bon
chiffre de la rolls validation des
retraites et puis c'est quoi le bon
chiffre de du déblocage du point à nice
mais le bon chiffre c'est celui qui
s'adapte à l'inflation
ce qu'elle cherchait les derniers
chiffres de l'inflation c'est la moyenne
des six derniers mois non mais comment
ça se calcule et comment vous faites
pour les cadres de catégorie c c'est à
dire ceux qui touchent le moins dans les
collectivités locales moi je pense qu'il
faut que ce soit supérieur je vais pas
vous lancer un chiffre parce que si je
vous dis 3 % alors qu'en réalité il
faudrait mettre 4,2 me et en fait il
faudrait plutôt mettre 4,5 à 4,8 pour
les cadres de catégorie c est bien ça
vous dit même si
c'est un new deal dans la société
française on va vers la société du plein
emploi et de l'inflation ce qu'a donné
comme ambition emmanuel macron c'est un
new deal à la roosevelt où on est
capable de relancer le pouvoir d'achat
de relancer la relocalisation
industrielle dans le pays et la
planification énergétique dans des
conditions qu'on n'avait jamais vécu son
crémant ce n'est pas la même chose pour
tout le monde mais ça c'est le travail
décent laisser travailler les c'est là
que sa passion pour le goût gers et oui
on n'a
pas suffisamment de dialogue social dans
ce pays et donc c'est sûrement pas un
parlementaire moi je suis très favorable
à ce qu'il y a un bien meilleur dialogue
entre le gouvernement et le parlement je
n'ai aucun problème avec ça mais en
revanche quand ça concerne les salariés
et en particulier sa la république
laisser travailler le gouvernement et
les syndicats juste une dernière
question sur la réindexation des
retraites donc ça va avoir lieu au mois
d'août est-ce que s'il ya encore
toujours cette inflation au mois de
janvier prochain une nouvelle hausse des
pensions de retraite c'est exactement ce
que je décrivais tout à l'heure quand
vous entrez dans une société durablement
inflation 6 nice c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui au fond ne fait complètement différé
du programme porté par jean luc
mélenchon meredith blocage des prix
comme si on était rentrés dans un moment
inflationnistes pour trois mois ou pour
un an en été on va voir une décennie
inflationnistes c'est ça qui est devant
nous et donc comme dans les années 50 60
70 même le début des années 80 il faut
qu'on ait à période régulière la
capacité d'ajuster toutes les pensions
fixe les pensions retraite les minima
sociaux on parlait à l'instant de la
fonction publique c'est exactement ce
sujet là on a besoin dans ce pays
d'avoir une conférence nationale
permanente sur les rémunérations
de 1000 euros c'est bien code à chaque
fois en fait on essaye de ne pas adapter
les pensions de retraite à celle de
madame bettencourt
mais si
on est bien d'accord mais si vous voulez
donner de l'argent mais mme bettencourt
oui vous êtes est mauvais vous êtes
favorable à un meilleur dialogue entre
parlement et gouvernement est ce que
vous même le modem vous avez des mesures
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat que vous
comptez portée lors du débat
parlementaire qui va s'ouvrir dans
quelques semaines on a eu une demande
particulière jeu j'en parlais à
l'instant sur le les cadres de catégorie
c dans la fonction publique et je pense
en particulier dans la fonction publique
territoriale où on a salué à raison les
soignants on a salué et à raison
les personnels dans les services fiscaux
ou dans les services de sécurité
je pense qu'on a trop peu penser aux
personnels qui étaient les petits
salaires de la fonction publique dans
les mairies et donc quand les
départements vous souhaitez paris dont
on souhaite tous effectivement le pouce
pour em en terre parce que forcément
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
quand vous êtes vraiment au bas de
l'échelle des salaires c'est là que vous
souffrez le plus de des à-coups
d'inflation et vous êtes en accord avec
le reste de la majorité là dessus il ya
vous en avez porté par le modem et puis
après on dit dans la majorité
on peut avoir des discussions on peut
avoir des exigences et je crois qu'on a
en tout cas plus de cohérence que la du
ps sur notre capacité à gérer
l'assemblée nationale ensemble allez on
parle des retraites à table oui la
retraite à 65 ans on n'entend pas
beaucoup parler la concertation va donc
commencer seulement en septembre est ce
que c'est un dossier que vous ne voulez
pas vous traîner pendant la campagne
législative un boulet
pas du tout alors on en parle est
enterrée mais non mais vous vous voyez
bien il n'y a pas
un français de bonne foi qu'ils
imaginent alors qu'on vit quinze ans de
plus qu'en 1981 qu' on puisse pas
discuter d'une réforme des retraites ça
c'est bien 19
15 ans de moins qu'aujourd'hui et on
partait à la retraite à 65 ans elle est
nécessaire équilibre est ce qu'elle est
nécessaire pour équilibrer le système
très deux choses et après je vais vous
dire comment on peut peut-être
travailler à un consensus elle est
nécessaire pour deux choses équilibrer
le système des retraites parce que moi
je veux pas être la première génération
de parlementaires qui sera pas capable
de servir les pensions de nos parents et
nos grands parents team à dire quelque
chose le conseil de nommer
servir le corps
il se trouve qu'en 2017
quand j'ai été élu pour la première fois
comme député le corps avait dit qu'il
n'y avait pas de problème avec le
financement des retraites en 2018 le cor
a publié un autre rapport disant qu'il
ya un problème de financement bien
partie du corps si vous voulez bien moi
je vous ai dit deux choses non mais on y
dit n'importe quoi le corps pour vous
vous ne le croyez pas lorsqu'il dit les
dépenses de retraites vont baisser à 11%
du pib en 2030
l'un des plus bas niveau en europe que
le coach a dit une chose l inverse entre
2017 et 2018 quand on est député et
qu'on doit prendre des décisions dans ce
cas là c'est pas très facile de
s'appuyer sur quelqu'un qui dit une
chose l inverse en un an voilà ce que je
dis moi je porte pas de jugement de
valeur je fais
deuxième chose si vous voulez bien me
laisser terminer la réforme des
retraites elle est nécessaire pour
financer la dépendance
un problème orpea et c'est oublier
qu'aujourd'hui on a des difficultés
et donc de financer la dépendance et pas
les retraites qui finança dépendance
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche c'est
que aujourd'hui si vous n'équilibre est
pas le régime des retraites et on sait
depuis 1992 corrompent accord depuis
michel rocard depuis 1992 on sait qu'en
entre 2032 et 2035 on aurait une
difficulté à équilibrer le régime il ya
tout simplement parce qu'en 1992 on
savait qu'elles étaient les bébés qui
avaient 20 ans à ce moment là et qu'ils
allaient rentrer sur le marché du
travail j'en fais partie et on savait
qu'elles étaient les générations qu'elle
est passée par partir à la retraite et
donc on sait qu'entre 2032 et 2035 y
aura un problème il se trouve que cette
assemblée devait être élu en 2022
jusqu'en 2027 si on n'est pas capable de
prendre des décisions en 2027 pour un
problème dont on sait depuis qu'il
ya pas de totem vous savez
c'est pourquoi c'est parce que ce qui va
déterminer l'âge in fine et c'est les
progrès sociaux qu'on veut mettre dans
cette réforme qu'est ce qu'on fait en
matière de pénibilité qu'est ce qu'on
fait en matière de carrière longue
qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière de
formation tout au long de la vie parce
que les générations qui rentrent sur le
marché du travail ils vont avoir trois
ou quatre métiers différents et si
possible de moins en moins pénible au
cours de leur vie qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour l'emploi des seniors parce que
c'est une des grandes difficultés du
marché du travail en france et enfin
comment on traite la question de la
transmission en fin de carrière ou sur
les dernières années où on va travailler
on va travailler un peu moins et
transmettre un peu plus aux générations
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail
dans une économie de compétences comme
la l'économie française tout ça c'est
des progrès sociaux très importants
parce que tout le monde est complètement
obsédé sur la sphère de l'âge c'est très
important l'âge savoir si on va partir
dix-huit mois avant 18 mois après dans
certains métiers manuels
mais le team et met immédiatement c'est
devenu un totem emmanuel macron quand il
a parlé vous étiez à sa conférence de
presse quand il a parlé du sujet de la
retraite il a parlé de tous ces sujets
là a dit comment on remet des progrès
sociaux dans la façon de travailler est
dans la façon de partir à la retraite
tous ces progrès sociaux ils ont un coût
et alors on discutera pour financer ces
progrès sociaux qui l'a beaucoup sont
directement liés au travail directement
lié à la difficulté du travail
à quel âge on partira elisabeth borgne a
évidemment raison de dire ben entre 64
et 65 oui si on veut pas mettre de
progrès sociaux peut-être qu'on dira 64
ça suffit si on veut mettre des progrès
sociaux peut-être qu'il faudra aller à
65 ben moi je préfère travailler jusqu'à
65 ans parce que j'ai pas un métier
pénible
mais financer le de meilleur ehpad pour
nos grands-parents et financé des vrais
progrès sociaux pour ceux qui sont au
bas de l'échelle sociale dans ce pays
d'un mot juste olivier grégoire
porte-parole du gouvernement a promis de
mener cette réforme sans brutalité est
ce que ça veut dire 149,3 à vos yeux est
ce que le modem s'opposerait à
l'utilisation du 49-3 lorca de ce débat
c'est malheureusement pas comme ça mais
vous le savez monsieur mairie que c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe qu'en fait
on peut pas s'opposer à 49 3 points peut
éventuellement ce que vous pouvez
refuser non
il faut faire une chose d'abord c'est se
donner le temps de travailler surtout
les progrès sociaux que je viens de
liste et parce que là dessus il ya du
grain à moudre comme on le dit parfois
dans les discussions avec l'accord
de sa rentabilité sur un âge on sait
qu'il ya une loi qui est en cours il
faut probablement le la modifier parce
que ça il faut dire la vérité aux
français c'est il n'y a que comme ça
qu'on s'en sortira ensuite ce que je
pense qu'il faut pas procéder comme on
l'avait fait la dernière fois c'est à
dire que commander déposé le texte un
peu tard il n'y avait pas pu avoir de
temps législatif programmé donc tout le
monde était parti dans une très grande
créativité d'amendements qui n'avait ni
queue ni tête moi j'y suis resté jour et
nuit pendant trois semaines et pendant
trois semaines
c'est qu'on arrive aux 42 points je
pense que là si on precinct bien la
réforme en amont on n'aura pas besoin
d'un local en poste à une question sur
la pénurie à martin hirsch aujourd'hui
qui a tiré la sonnette d'alarmé à manque
1400 infirmiers rien qu'en ile-de-france
ya aussi patrick peu loin qui nous dit
déjà une averti des services en ti vont
fermer cet été c'est à dire demain
qu'est ce que vous proposez il en manque
de lure plusieurs centaines déjà on voit
des d'aider les urgences avaient retenti
dans la nuit du dans le cadre de ce new
deal dont je parlais tout à l'heure on
doit être capable d'adapter les salaires
à l'inflation et aux besoins de la
société
ce que je vois c'est qu'il faut creuser
à dire j'allais vous répondre maintenant
tout de suite c'est à dire c'est on a
besoin de creuser deux choses comment on
rémunère mieux les nuits comme on
rémunère mieux les week-ends ce que la
question là c'est juillet août comment
on va passer juillet avec des soignants
qui ont besoin de vacances parce qu'ils
ont le droit d'être fatigué bien
légitime un certain nombre d'entre eux
qui est
un peu écoeuré de la situation qui vient
de se dérouler pendant deux ans vu une
telle crise c'est difficile en cas de
démission
puis furent quai
ceci étant aggravée par soit dans les
grandes villes les difficultés à se
loger parce que les salaires sont trop
bas malgré le ségur de la santé on a
encore des salaires qui sont trop bas
pour se loger à paris par exemple mais
c'est la même chose à lyon à bordeaux à
strasbourg quoi on augmente les salaires
mais on généralise
de choses à faire moi je crois que la
question des primes de nuit et des
primes de week-end
en fait c'est débloqué un budget
spécifique ça rentre dans les projets de
loi de finances rectificative herminis
tout à l'heure devant le les
parlementaires de la majorité nous
annoncer qu'elle avait demandé à
brigitte bourguignon de travailler sur
ces sujets moi faire partie
exactement moi je pense que dès le mois
de juin la nouvelle majorité qui sortira
des urnes j'espère que les élections
nous seront favorables nous pourrions
proposer une augmentation des budgets
dans chaque hôpital pour pouvoir
augmenter les nuits et les week-ends
deuxième chose mieux travaillé que la
médecine de ville il faut que ce soit
fait beaucoup plus dans la concertation
que
parce que ça a été fait un peu dans la
précipitation au cours des derniers
jours la troisième chose c'est aussi la
question des conditions de travail parce
qu'elle croyait bien que
il ya aussi à organiser dans les
services en faisant confiance au terrain
il ya prendre des initiatives pour que
les gens se sentent mis aussi parce
qu'il ya des endroits où on a augmenté
les salaires on a augmenté les budgets
des hôpitaux où ils peuvent embaucher
lisant les moyens d'embaucher est
embauché à des bons salaires mais les
gens ne viennent pas parce qu'il ya
aussi une condition la baisse alors il
ya un problème justement c'est la
dernière question dans d'autres secteurs
en france et notamment dans la
restauration 360 mille emplois non
pourvus cet été annonce lui émis h le
principal syndicat dans l'hôtellerie il
en train de négocier une convention avec
la tunisie pour faire venir des serveurs
tunisien peut-être dès cet été est-ce
que vous soutenez cette démarche ou
est-ce que ça vous choque
je pense que dans le secteur privé
chacun peut prendre les initiatives qui
veut j'aimerais bien qu'ils aboutissent
une négociation de branche dans le
domaine de l'hôtellerie tourisme
restauration mais sur
la négociation et salue une augmentation
de salaire mais aujourd'hui la question
du statut
des week-ends des jours d'affilée où on
travaille en finale il n'y avait jamais
eu de négociations c'est c'est six dans
le new deal budgétaires financiers
salariale dont je parlais tout à l'heure
il peut y avoir aussi un new deal social
et que des secteurs d'activité qui n'ont
jamais entamé de négociations sur les
conditions de travail pouvait le faire
dire s'ils doivent trouver des solutions
à court terme jeu qu'ils le fassent mais
enfin dans un pays qui a encore 7 % de
chômeurs on n'est pas au chômage
structurel
et ses 7 % ce n'est pas tous des
feignants et bat donné leur envie de
travailler en les payant mieux et en
organisant mieux les conditions de
travail moi j'avais un grand père qui
était restaurateur vient et quand on
trouvait pas
dans les veillées organisées mais les
conditions de travail merci à mme tran
huy merci clément mérite d'avoir été
avec nous pour interroger patrick
mignola dans un instant c'est à yves
thréard qui va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau avant c'est une question sur la
proportionnelle on sait que c'est un
nouveau combat au modem est ce que vous
avez eu un accord ferme cette fois que
la proportionnelle s'offrait on se
souvient qu'en 2017 ça faisait partie de
la corde de france abat héros de son
ralliement à emmanuel macron et puis on
n'a pas eu la proportionnelle alors
c'est pourquoi
président de la république s'est exprimé
pendant la campagne présidentielle sur
ce sujet il les dit très clairement
d'ailleurs dans un événement qui était à
pau à côté de françois bayrou donc je
pense que françois belloy bien entendu
ce qu'il avait dit en disant que sa
préférence personnelle était pour une
proportionnelle d'ailleurs
proportionnelle dit intègre alors pas
tout à fait intégral c'est que le
meilleur projet de proportionnelle à mes
yeux c'est le projet qui était celui de
françois mitterrand en 1986 qui avait
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce qu'on dit
dégagé une majorité rpr udf à l'époque
c'est celui on a une proportionnelle
départementale dans tous les
départements de france avec la même
règle et avec une distribution de sièges
à partir de 5 % moi je pense que ce
serait sage
et même que c'est obligatoire si un tire
pas les conséquences
des élections locales où il ya eu 30 %
de participation et d'une élection
présidentielle où il seulement 70% de
participation c'est qu'on n'a pas
compétence des ça chaque élection doit
le faire rapidement par une loi simple
au lendemain des législatives
moi je prendrai toutes mes
responsabilités pour que aboutissent le
la proportionnelle au cours de cette
législature
je pense que s'il est bien une personne
en france qui est consciente des
difficultés de notre démocratie et de la
nécessité d'un nouveau pacte civique et
social ces manuels maintenant ils
feraient arnaud a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir yves bon sens vous est hésitant
réalise directeur adjoint au figaro et
vous vouliez parler des législatives bah
oui on va parler mais justement parce
que bonjour patrick mignola mais
vous êtes partis sur le la
proportionnelle je voudrais continuer un
tout petit peu si vous permettez sur les
institutions parce que c'était un des
grands chantiers du président de la
république sortant réélu et c'est un
chantier qui a été complètement laissé
tomber il ya une réforme
institutionnelle est ce que cette
réforme peut avoir lieu dans ce second
mandat la proportionnelle comme l'a dit
moritz et une loi simple mais une
réforme ou eh bien on envisage le
référendum d'initiative populaire
citoyenne ou eh bien on ajoute quelques
mots sur l'écologie dans les premiers
dans les premiers articles enfin une
vraie réforme qui nécessite peut-être
lusage du référendum ce qui était prévu
d'ailleurs dans la réforme
constitutionnelle comportait qu'on n'a
pas pu faire aboutir dans le cas
précédent il ya effectivement les
engagements écologiques il doit en faire
partie oui
il ya un élément important aussi sur le
l'évolution de l'autorité judiciaire oui
je pense qu'il ya un sujet fondamental
ce sujet de la différenciation parmi
ceux que vous ne vais pas citer
différenciation cet article soit 60
77 et 78
ans a déjà été votée mais
malheureusement on n'a pas pu aller au
bout de la réforme est donc aujourd'hui
si on les associations faut qu'on
comprenne parce que c'est la
différenciation de la loi à des lois
damrémont territoire c'est à dire que
les fondamentaux le régalien et les
grands équilibres économiques et sociaux
doivent rester nationaux c'est une
évidence mais souvent dans les
collectivités c'est selon qu'on est en
montagne ou selon qu'on est dans
l'intervalle selon qu'on est en
métropole ou selon que on est dans des
espaces ruraux
l'application de la loi pourrait être un
peu différente c'est fondamental en
termes d'application de la loi et donc
le fait qu'on puisse avancer sur ce
sujet institutionnels ça peut nous
permettre d avancer outre-mer des
avancées corse et je pense que ça pourra
faire la satisfaction de beaucoup de
maires en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux parce que moi
j'aimerais bien que dans ce quinquennat
on vivent pas à nouveau la guerre
attisée par les oppositions entre les
villes et les campagnes entre les
métropoles et la ruralité vous souhaitez
donc que cette réforme un stick
constitutionnel ait lieu oui dans ce
pays mais ça s'il faut le faire dès le
début du quinquennat
ce qu'on doit faire dès le début du
quinquennat c'est les sujets de pouvoir
d'achat c'est les grands chantiers de
écologie écoles et
ensuite si on peut le porter à
référendum mais vous savez qu'en matière
constitutionnelle
autant pour faire un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne président de la
république c'est s'est engagée à
abaisser le seuil et moi je suis
d'accord avec cette idée huit cent mille
citoyens ou 700000 vallourec pour porter
un élément à votation comme on dit en
suisse ça fonctionne très bien mais pour
arriver à soumettre à référendum une
réforme institutionnelle il faut que
assemblée et sénat vote dans les mêmes
termes l'article 89 de la confier à des
tiers et ensuite qu'on aille à
référendum d'accord aux deux tiers la
majorité c'est pas une majorité simple
que chacun vote et soit on fait grève
aux deux tiers 2/3 en congrès soit on
fait un référendum alors les
législatives brigitte en parlait grands
sujets on en parle on en parle nommer
les français on parle très peu
d'ailleurs 1
vous avez commencé à vous avez du mal à
les réveiller à les intéresser surtout
moi vous avez une soixantaine de députés
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous visez plus
de députés dans la nouvelle assemblée au
jeu j'aimerais beaucoup parce qu'on a
107 candidats
qui travaillent sur le terrain en ce
moment à et parmi lesquels il ya
des jeunes pousses parmi lesquels il ya
des gens qui représentent
qui représente la chair de la société
française j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils y
accèdent effectivement à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui est important c'est
surtout ce qu'on va faire ensuite
j'ai confiance dans les candidats qu'on
présente au nom de votre
actif mais notre objectif c'est d'avoir
déjà une majorité pour la majorité ce
que les choses allaient les choses sont
pas gagné est-ce que vous aurez la
majorité absolue c'est le jour d'hui
aujourd'hui je ne le semble attention
oui ensemble renaissance mouvement
démocrate agir agir horizons je ne sais
pas si on aura une majorité vous êtes à
quai oui parce que je sens et même je
crains des formes de
radicalisation et de violence dans le
débat public qui sont alimentées
notamment par jean-luc mélenchon par
jean luc mélenchon d'un côté et depuis
quelques jours ça y est on les a vus
revenir sur le terrain également par le
par l'extrême droite vous les avez fait
un petit peu aidé avec ce qui s'est
passé au stade de france moi je
j'aimerais alors je suis pas sûr qu'on
ait voulu les aider mais vous avez
raison de relever que quand il ya du
désordre ça nourrit plutôt les extrêmes
que que les parties responsables et
c'est pour ça que c'est bien que le
gouvernement prenne des mesures en la
matière mais
on vit cette situation très particulière
où désormais la vie politique est coupée
en trois
et vous où les parties sont des extrêmes
vous oubliez les absences et moi
j'aimerais oui mais voyez au fond c'est
normal que des gens s'abstiennent si le
choix qu'ils ont c'est la majorité
présidentielle et deux extrémistes et
parce que quand on se retrouve dans
cette situation là oui le moi je suis
très choqué au fond je préférerais qu'on
ait un débat entre cette majorité
centrale une gauche de gouvernement à
une droite de gouvernement et oui mais
vous l'avez vous les avez vous les avez
tué d'une certaine façon parce que vous
proposez des cartes et leurs députés
mais pourquoi donc
parce que vous avez pas capté lors
débuter là on a toujours 103 ou 104
débuté hier à l'assemblée il ya toujours
27 ou baisser l'assurance
à plusieurs reprises ce procès fait à
emmanuel macron et à la majorité sa
constance qui voudrait que la droite
républicaine à la gauche républicaine et
disparus par notre fait c'est pourquoi
ils ont disparu c'est parce que depuis
cinq ans il pensait que emmanuel macron
était un accident de l'histoire et que
nous majorité parlementaire serions
d'une parenthèse c'est bien mais oui
mais ça veut dire que pendant ce temps
là ils n'ont pas réfléchi et deux côtés
ils se sont fait totalement absorbé par
jean luc mélenchon et de l'autre on a
une et cette radicalité
lecteurs vous arrange tantôt côté le pen
tantôt aimé le côté observé que c'est
votre président de la sem le président
de la république y à t aurais théorisé
cette opposition entre les gens qui sont
dans la mondialisation et puis les gens
qui se sentent un peu laissés pour
compte ils sont représentés d'ailleurs
parmi les aides il est tiré une
consécration il est allé voir moi je
pense que gauche républicaine et droite
républicaine frémit se remette à
travailler d'accord plutôt que se faire
absorber par l'osec sommes alors est-ce
que
vous voyez avec crainte l'arrivée à la
présidence de la commission des finances
si j'avais ces danube est ce qui devient
votre premier parti d'opposition est
bien la règle veut c'est une coutume que
la commission des finances soit confié
la présidence au premier groupe
d'opposition est-ce que ça serait une
bonne chose moi je n'y verrais pas
d'inconvénient
à ce que j'ai toujours perçu
objections en fait s'est confiée à un
groupe d'opposition
moi je ne verrais aucun inconvénient
est ce que dans cette assemblée les
extrêmes qui habituellement s'exprime
dans la rue ou dans les médias soit plus
responsabiliser face aux responsabilités
est-ce que c'est facile de critiquer
c'est facile d'aller agité des grands
mots de de faire campagne sous
vociférations en prétendant que sa
personne est sacrée
ça n'a pas nui à jean luc mélenchon à la
présidentielle un score excellent
soit claire boucher jean luc mélenchon
il a perdu la présidentielle il a beau
prétendre que emmanuel macron a pas
gagné j'ai bien l'impression que jean
lui belge en a perdu la présidentielle
les 90 de l'élire premier ministre alors
qu'il n'est pas candidat aux élections
législatives
ça ne soit pas candidat non je trouve ça
complètement fou et je trouve ça et je
trouve ça même un peu dangereux dire au
fond mais je vais pas m'inquiéter de
capacité de la de la santé
intellectuelle des uns et les autres
mais franchement
on demande aux gens de nous élire sans
être candidat alors que quand on a été
candidat on a perdu c'est un peu
dangereux pour la démocratie peut faire
croire aux gens qu'on pourrait être élu
sans être candidat et ça veut dire
qu'une fois qu'on est en place on va se
maintenir sans élection non plus est ce
que c'est on est en train de rentrer
dans une mécanique où tout le monde est
à l'envers donc on va se remettre à des
talents alors justement et on va aller
aux élections
aller aux élections
est réélu parce qu'il est maire de il
est maire du havre hui
les conditions soient maires de grandes
villes ou alors ça m'a échappé mais est
ce que est ce que vous allez garder la
présidence du groupe modem s'y est ce
que vous voulez la garde et je le
souhaite je souhaite rester assez
votre mine inquiète sur le résultat de
ces listes est possible effectivement
depuis l'élection présidentielle il ya
eu le on a complètement changer de
contexte économique vous l'avez évoqué
avec brigitte tout à l'heure il ya eu
l'affairé abad
ya l'histoire du stade de france avec un
ministre de l'intérieur qui est un peu
dans le déni de réalité me semble-t-il
est ce que tout ça ça peut pas faire le
lit justement de vaud opposition y tout
fait et le vrai risque dans cette
campagne électorale c'est qu'au fond sur
la base
d'une forme de désintérêt parce qu'au
lendemain d'une présidentielle on
s'intéresse peut-être un peu moins aux
élections législatives et puis
qu'ensuite de des éléments d'actualité
qui sont importants mais qui ne sont pas
en train de traiter les cinq années à
venir pour le pays effectivement il
puisse y avoir une forme d' accident
électoral moi je crains une forme d'
accident électoral qui conduisent vivre
au fond soit pour la majorité
présidentielle
qui conduisent le pays une forme
d'instabilité et donc moi je pense que
il faut redire ce qu'est l'enjeu le
président de la république il n'a pas
seulement été relus il a fixé une grande
ambition pour le pays laquelle est
l'ambition c'est d'avoir un new deal
économique et social un nouveau pacte
civil et social que je décrivais tout à
l'heure où parce que nous vivons dans
une société du plein emploi et de
l'inflation on doit adapter toutes les
relations économiques et sociales tous
les grands enjeux écologiques de demain
à une configuration qui est complètement
nouvelle et donc faut redonner de
l'optimisme aux français parce que s'ils
sont inquiets c'est parce qu'il sent
qu'il ya des changements fondamentaux
qui sont en train de travailler en
profondeur la société et qu'on n'y
répond pas ce gilet jaune pourrait
revenir mais oui 20 de ses ventes si
nous ne parvenons pas à faire une chose
c'est tuer l'idée de résignation et de
déclin dans le pays il faut qu'on tue
cette idée de résignation et de déclin
et que nous nous soyons la majorité de
la stabilité à une question m rassurez
moi est ce que françois bayrou emmanuel
macron s'entendent toujours bien
je la crois voir monsieur bayrou un peu
déçu de la composition du gouvernement
oui mais pas très bien représentées il
est vrai
on a évité la sur-représentation
excessive mais les choses vont
s'arranger
vous pensez que ça va s'arranger après
les cet hiver un remaniement moi je le
souhaite parce qu'il ya des il ya des
personnes qui sont talentueux je le dis
d'autant plus facilement que suis pas
concerné par le sujet puisque ayant fait
un infarctus il ya trois mois je vais
pas me jeter et faire la queue pour un
ticket d'entrée au gouvernement dia mais
il ya des gens talentueux au sein du
mouvement démocrate je le dis tout à
l'heure de nos députés qui bossent sur
le terrain et les nouveaux candidats
démocrates sous l'étiquette de la
majorité présidentielle sont des
personnes qui surtout
ressent que le pays ressentent la chair
du pays
de nouveau rentrer au gouvernement après
les 7,6 merci et participe à tressignaux
là d'avoir accepté notre invitation des
auditions publiques merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis pas d'audition
publique la semaine prochaine à cause de
la pentecôte mais vous retrouverez
elizabeth martichoux au lendemain du
premier tour des élections législatives
très bonne soirée sur lcp et public
sénat
[Musique]